lever les vaccins les brevets sur les
vaccins contre le coc vie pour accélérer
leur diffusion se disant favorable à une
telle mesure l'amérique de joe biden a
non seulement surpris mais l'os qui jeté
un pavé dans la mare washington a beau
mettre en avant les circonstances
exceptionnelles liées à la pandémie
n'est évidemment pas au goût de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir seller dit
aux échos bonsoir jacques alors levé 1
les mauvais sur les vaccins évidemment
ça fait parler
joe biden serait-il donc devenu
mélenchonistes ont bien cela ne serait
finalement qu'un gros coup de com ou
alors effectivement s'ils voulaient
cette déclaration du président by dane a
beaucoup surpris
elle ajoutait d'ailleurs un certain
trouble lors de la réunion des
dirigeants de l'union européenne qui se
tenait à porto il ya quelques jours où
on a pu voir que certains étaient tout à
fait enthousiaste en particulier le
premier ministre espagnol
d'autres étaient plus réservé comme
notre président et puis certains étaient
carrément contre comme angela merkel
disons le tout de suite
venant de la part du président d'un pays
qui gardent pratiquement la totalité de
sa production pour lui qui d'une
certaine manière à a mis un embargo à
l'exportation sauf de toutes petites
quantités pour le canada et pour le
mexique et qui m'aiment organise une
forme d' embargo sur les produits
nécessaires pour produire ces vaccins
c'est ça pose problème et on peut se
demander effectivement si c'est pas un
petit peu un coup de com
maintenant il faut dire aussi que c'est
une vraie question
et compte tenu de l'importance de la
vaccination le fait qu'il faudra
probablement que l'on produise dans le
monde entre 14 et 16 milliards de doses
et bien effectivement on peut poser le
problème alors jacques tout d'abord où
on est la vaccination alors la
vaccination avance mais avec d'énormes
je dis bien
d'énormes différences suivant les
régions l'asie on a le sentiment que
l'asie est en avance sur cette
vaccination
mais compte tenu de la population qui
lie à en asie et bien en fait ça reste
relativement faible
on voit bien et s a été justement une
virée l'un des sujets que vous avez
abordé il ya quelques minutes
l'amérique du sud est très peu vaccinés
alors globalement pour l'instant il ya
grosso modo un sixième de la population
du monde qui a été vaccinée il faudrait
en vacciner normalement 5/6
on voit donc l'immensité du problème il
y a donc jacques de grosses différences
entre pays riches et pays pauvres
oui tout à fait tout à fait c'est là
aussi de manière très très visible l'une
des principales différences que l'on a
alors bien sûr il ya aussi des problèmes
de logistique
si vous voulez et ce sont par exemple
ces problèmes qui ont pu expliquer le
retard pris par la france mais il y a
aussi des problèmes de production et on
voit par exemple l'inde est grosso modo
au troisième rang pour les pays vacciner
en nombre mais rapportée à la population
de l'inde
je rappelle que la population de l'inde
est supérieur à 1,3 milliard d'habitants
ça reste extrêmement faible donc oui il
y à d'énormes différences entre pays
alors si c'est une question de
disponibilité de président baydan at il
eu raison de proposer la levée des
brevets sur les vaccins ce qui est
intéressant si vous voulez c'est que là
on voit bien que un job hayden réagi ou
pense que les vaccins ce sont grosso
modo les vaccins qui sont produits aux
états-unis ou en association avec les
états unis
comme si la totalité des vaccins va ça
se résumer à yzeure bio ntech moderna
johnson & johnson voir astrazeneca dont
je rappelle qu'il n'est toujours pas
homologué aux états unis mais en fait on
a d'autres vaccins on a beaucoup
d'autres vaccins on a les vaccins
chinois sinovac et les deux autres et
puis on a ce pique nique v le vaccin
russe
donc en fait en réalité cette question
des vaccins elle est très complexe et si
on pose la question de la levée des
brevets il va falloir tenir compte aussi
du fait que les stratégies des
compagnies sont très différentes par
exemple
fabio ntech moderna johnson & johnson
astrazeneca eux ils vendent des doses
mais si on regarde maintenant scouts
migrer le fonds russe pour les
investissements directs qui
commercialise skotnik vais lui vend déjà
des licences
autrement dit on voit qu'il y à déjà un
mécanisme de partage des brevets parce
que vendre une licence c'est tout
simplement vendre un brevet alors vous
voulez dire que cette levée des vaccins
seraient inefficaces
en d'autres mots exactement je pense que
oui c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
penser aujourd'hui mais à partir du
moment où on va vendre ou donner
gratuitement le brevet et bien il n'y a
qu'un nombre assez limité de pays qui
ont la capacité justement d'exploiter ce
brevet qui choix payant ou qu'ils soient
gratuits
autrement dit il s'agit des pays qui ont
déjà de bonnes capacités à
pharmaceutiques mais qui n'ont pas pour
l'instant de vaccins alors y en a parmi
ces pays
il ya aussi normalement la france
puisque pour l'instant il n'y a pas sauf
gérer cette petite cette petite start up
française qui est du côté de nantes
mais les grandes compagnies
pharmaceutiques françaises n'ont pas
développé pour l'instant leur propre
vaccin et puis à d'autres pays
il ya la corée du sud il ya le japon
donc là c'est plutôt à ces pays là que
s'adresse d'une certaine manière
l'offre de joe biden après il faut quand
même ça vous
alors qu' un certain nombre de ces pays
ils ont déjà commencé à acheter des
licences
prenons le cas de l'inde va produire
sous licence spoutnik v mais aussi des
vaccins chinois et probablement de
l'asra zeneca d'autres pays sont en
train de négocier ses licences la corée
du sud a déjà acheté la licence de
scouts migré il y à une société
italienne qui a acheté la licence
donc on voit bien que d'une certaine
manière le processus de partage des
licences
il a déjà lieu alors il faut
certainement accéléré de ce point de vue
là la proposition de joe biden fait sens
mais il faut quand même se rappeler que
ce processus de partage des licences et
bien ça va faire en sorte que par
exemple spoutnik v une grosse partie des
doses spoutnik v qui seront sur le
marché mondial d'ici la fin du mois de
mai ou le début du mois de juin
mais elles seront produites en inde
elles seront produites en corée et elles
seront à terme produite en italie
alors à vous en tant tout est facile
jacques est ce aussi simple que cela
quand de se lancer dans une ligne de
production non évidemment
il faut bien comprendre que ça demande
des capacités quand même extrêmement
particulière il faut avoir déjà une
industrie pharmaceutique développer
maintenant ce n'est pas nécessairement
un processus qui prendra du temps
si on prend l'inde encore puisque l'inde
si vous voulez acheter le la licence de
spoutnik v eh bien on voit très bien que
l'inde va pouvoir produire le vaccin
russe en quatre à cinq mois
donc c'est à peu près ça le temps qu'une
qu'un pays dont l'industrie est déjà à
bon niveau peut produire un vaccin s'il
obtient la licence mais la question des
licences est loin d'être la seule
et c'est ça qu'on oublie très souvent et
quand on prouve
puis un sérum quand on produit un vaccin
il faut des matières premières or
aujourd'hui ces matières premières sont
d'abord en pénurie
il y en a pas assez pour tout le monde
et puis deuxièmement elles sont elles
mêmes couvert par des brevets donc ça
veut dire que c'est pas simplement les
brevets des vaccins qui devraient être à
partager ce sont aussi les brevets des
matières premières alors pourquoi une
telle déclaration
alors c'est effectivement un une
question intéressante
on peut penser évidemment que le
président bart hayden s'est dit que
c'était une manière de redorer un petit
peu l'image des états unis parce que
c'est vrai que l'image des états unis
elle a été à l'extérieur je pars pas à
l'intérieur elle était à l'extérieur un
petit peu abîmés par la politique
extrêmement protectionnistes des états
unis qui se gardent pour eux comme je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure
non seulement la grande majorité de leur
production de vaccins mais aussi et
c'est encore plus important
la production des matières premières qui
servent à faire du vaccin on peut aussi
penser que joe biden a vu comment des
pays comme la chine comme la russie sont
en train de se construire une image dans
le monde à travers l'offre de leurs
vaccins et surtout la proposition de
leurs licences de production et donc il
s'est dit ça il faut d'une certaine
manière faire la même chose et faire la
même chose qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est bien ça veut dire essentiellement
ouvrir les licences des brevets non
conclusion jacques ce serait même un
coin guéna merkel qui auraient raison
alors si vous voulez c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué que ça là encore emmanuel
macron évidemment a mis le doigt sur des
problèmes qu'il y avait dans cette
ouverture des brevets mais il
ne dis pas non plus l'essentiel qui est
la question de construire une capacité
industrielle au niveau international bon
en ce qui concerne la madame angela
merkel il est trop évident que dans son
opposition à l'ouverture des brevets
elle défend les intérêts de bioéthique
la société qui est associé à pfizer et
qui est d'origine allemand si on reprend
si vous voulez globalement cette
question on voit qu'il ya trois
problèmes le premier problème c'est la
question justement est-ce qu'il faudra
de nouveaux vaccins pour lutter contre
deux nouveaux variants et dans ce cas là
est ce que les brevets de ces nouveaux
vaccins seront ou de ses variantes de
ces vaccins pour lutter contre les
variants de l'aco vie est ce que ces
brevets seront aussi ouverts c'était un
point sur lequel joe by dane est resté
strictement silencieuse saas est un
premier point le deuxième point c'est
comment on organise au niveau mondial la
production la plus importante de ces
vaccins et là encore ce sont des choses
qui sont extrêmement complexes parce
qu'on voit bien que ça ne sert à rien de
donner une licence un pays qui n'a pas
la capacité
ça ne sert à rien de donner une licence
un pays qui a la capacité mais qui n'a
pas les matières premières nécessaires
pour produire le vaccin
bref il faut concevoir la production des
vaccins comme un ensemble global allant
de l'amont à l'aval des matières
premières au produit fini et pour cela
je pense qu'il faut s'inspirer de ce qui
a été fait dans le cadre des économies
de guerre dans le cadre de la production
de guerre c'est encore là on sait le
mieux faire ce genre de choses et puis
il ya une troisième question et cette
troisième question ça pose évidemment
c'est la question du prix est là si vous
voulez la vente des brevets n'est pas ou
disons le l'ouverture des brevets n'est
pas la seule solution il ya d'autres
solutions comme par exemple des
contrôles de prix ce qu'on appelle les
price cap qui limite l'effet de rente
qu'on peut dont on peut tirer d'un
brevet ou encore des taxes sur les
profits que réalisera les sociétés